Sony Pictures animation spider-man into
the spider-verse is finally here and it
is in a word amazing with a few tweaks
the next entry in the spider-verse saga
could be even better
here are some aspects which the
filmmakers totally nailed and some which
left a little very very little room for
improvement but be warned some
spectacularly minor spoilers abound the
film's animation is pretty much
incredible it looks as if it were ripped
from the pages of a comic book in more
ways than one not only is the character
designed pretty much perfect but the
film makes frequent clever use of comic
book tropes like dialog boxes and sound
effects which are spelled out on screen
at times the animation straddles a fine
line between the styles of comic books
and cartoons which is altogether
appropriate for a PG rated film
featuring the first on-screen appearance
of the spectacular spider ham an
alternate version of Spidey who is a
talking anthropomorphic pig I just wash
my hands that's why they're wet no other
reason into the spider verse takes full
advantage of its medium with knockout
action sequences that would have been
difficult if not impossible to create in
live-action and characters that simply
wouldn't have worked otherwise but for
all that into the spider verse gets
right in this respect there's one
aesthetic choice that could have perhaps
been reined in a little bit the
filmmakers took the comics inspired look
of the film - in Xtreme never before
seen on film and when it works it really
works but when it doesn't it becomes
distracting the film's backgrounds
sometimes become intentionally blurry
seemingly in order to help keep the
viewers focus in the middle of the
screen
it's a strange contrast with the clean
sharp lines of the characters and
foregrounds but at times it doesn't so
much invoke comic book art as it does
threaten to give the viewer a headache
into the spider verse finally gives
Spidey fans the first big screen
appearance of Miles Morales afro-latino
teen who took over a spider-man in the
now-defunct ultimate universe before
plot vaccinations transplanted him into
the mainstream Marvel continuity the
voice performance by shameik Moore is
spot-on expertly capturing miles is
awkward this humour and determination
can spider
visible not my universe you just poked
me in my eye this is incredible some
kind of fight or flight back what's that
he makes every step of the teen's arc
for a vulnerable kid to badass hero ring
true and he has an excellent chemistry
with a pudgy schlubby alternate universe
Peter Parker voiced by Jake Johnson but
unfortunately that chemistry also serves
to highlight one of the flicks other
shortcomings into the spider verse
employs a hilarious device to introduce
all of its alternate Spidey's at the
film's beginning Peter Parker briefly
explains his origin and career as
spider-man in a voiceover my name is
Peter Parker and pretty sure you know
the rest I saved the city fell in love
then I saved the city again
and again it's simple it's concise and
it's repeated by each of the new
Spidey's as they're introduced to the
film this device is so light-hearted and
funny that it's easy to ignore how it
effectively glosses over the origins and
careers of these other characters but it
does and this kind of stinks we miss out
on learning about the universes of
spider-man noir Penny Parker and spider
ham while the emissions make sense from
a storytelling standpoint the movie is
so fun that we can't help but want more
the characters shine during their brief
time on screen but the truncated
introductions end up leaving the
alternate Spidey's feeling just a bit
underdeveloped well all of them that is
except one voiced by Hailee Steinfeld
into the spider versus Gwen is
everything fans could have hoped for
highly capable and with the mix of
compassionate sarcasm that's a hallmark
of any Spidey
hey guys Wanda it's Gwen actually oh you
know her very cool both the character
and Steinfeld's performance are
appealing enough that it's no wonder
sony has greenlit an all-female into the
spider-verse
spin-off in which Gwen will almost
certainly take the lead sure into the
Spider versus now only just hitting
theaters but spider Gwen's return to the
big screen can't come soon enough into
the spider-verse features more than one
villain but discussing them all would
venture a bit too far into spoiler
territory the film's biggest bad is
Wilson Fisk aka the kingpin and while
it's a perfectly acceptable choice
considering the characters long history
with Spidey some fans might find that
this version of Fisk leaves a bit to be
desired for starters the characters
rendering is pretty distracting as he is
roughly the size and shape of a minivan
and literally shaped like one as well
easily four or five times larger than
any other human character in the film
considering how ridiculous he looks in a
movie with an actual talking cartoon pig
it's actually kind of impressive all
that aside into the spider verse remains
one of the very best superhero movies
released in 2018 and with competition
from the likes of Black Panther Deadpool
2 and infinity war that's really saying
something
ACK selecting a bagel spider-man you
know
funny I get that a lot Hey
[Music]